bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte sur
LCP au programme le 26 octobre une
audition sur un sujet serpent de mer
l'état général des prisons en France les
députés entendent Dominique Simoneau
elle est contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté et les députés
l'interrogent longuement sur les
conditions de détention et les
dysfonctionnements de la politique
pénitentiaire
général je vous présenter les grandes
lignes de votre apport je tiens à
rappeler que la commission des lois
demeure très attentive à la préservation
de la dignité des personnes privées de
liberté tout particulièrement aux
conditions de détention il y a pour cela
un rapport qui était rendu le 12 janvier
dernier à la commission d'enquête visant
à identifier les dysfonctionnements et
les manquements de la politique
pénitentiaire française dont notre
collègue Caroline Navali était
rapporteur avec Monsieur Philippe
Benassaya qui était le président
cette mission cette commission d'enquête
elle a confirmé combien cette vigilance
reste nécessaire ne serait-ce qu'à
raison d'être densité carcérale donc
vous allez certainement nous parler
densité carcéral qui est de 118% c'est à
dire 71 700 personnes détenues pour un
peu plus de 60 000 places
opérationnelles et avec une densité
carcérale qui est encore plus importante
dans les seules maisons d'arrêt donc
c'est pour cela que j'ai souhaité qu'on
fasse en plus de la diffusion de ce
rapport donc tous les collègues qui sont
présents aujourd'hui ont eu connaissance
en dépit du fait qu'il s'agit d'un
rapport de la précédente législature
qu'on fasse un déplacement au centre
pénitentiaire de Fresnes avant même de
vous recevoir ce déplacement il a eu
lieu le vendredi 14 octobre dernier une
visite qui a permis de faire le point
sur l'évolution des conditions des
tensions dans l'établissement de
constater les efforts entrepris en
matière de salubrité de conditions de
vie il y a déjà des travaux qui ont été
faits dans les cours de promenade sur la
réflexion de certaines cellules sur
l'accès individuel au sanitaire c'est
pas une une mince affaire il y a
toujours pas de douche dans un
cellulement pour ce qui concerne Fred on
a pu le constater aussi
on a rencontré les personnels aussi qui
sont particulièrement mobilisés alors on
les a rencontrés pour ce qui concerne la
gestion de la détention pour la gestion
l'organisation des des cours également
qui ont lieu à Fresnes pour ce qui
concerne le travail avec le nouveau
contrat de travail qui est entré en
vigueur et donc chacun aussi a peut
mesurer que la prison est
particulièrement Fresnes on était loin
des caricatures loin des de l'idylle qui
pourrait être celle de notre prison et
de prison parfaites que on s'imagine
tous mais en tout cas loin des
caricatures qui en sont faites et avec
un effort particulier pour la
réinsertion sociale détenue donc le
champ d'intervention de votre autorité
vous avez procédé l'an dernier à plus
d'une centaine de visites alors là
j'étais impressionné de le lire ça c'est
mine pas aux prisons d'autres lieux de
privation de liberté sans visite c'était
quand même particulièrement
impressionnant donc c'est à dire que
vous êtes allés dans des établissements
psychiatriques dans les centres de
rétention administratives un thème qui
nous intéressera à priori au premier
trimestre 2023
ou encore dans des locaux de détention
ou de garde à vue j'ai vous donner la
parole tout de suite après quelques
questions mes collègues vous
interrogeront pour une durée de deux
minutes ils en ont désormais l'habitude
moi je voudrais que vous puissiez nous
dresser un bilan de l'application de vos
recommandations et ce qu'elles ont été
suivies dans quel délai avec quel taux
de
finalement de performance par rapport à
ce que vous aviez ça vie exigé qu'est-ce
qui ne l'est pas encore assez et quel
établissement ont particulièrement
retenu votre attention j'avais une
attention particulière sur le centre de
Bedenac où vous étiez rendu notamment en
Charente-Maritime
si vous aviez des recommandations
particulières devant la commission des
lois et puis une note plus personnelle
puisque vous avez récemment fait une
visite au Centre Henri Labory 30 mai au
18 juin dernier c'est un centre
hospitalier d'un établissement
psychiatrique qui est situé dans la
circonscription j'ai rejoint le conseil
de surveillance de cette établissement
comme milieu autorise la loi depuis la
loi d'avril 2021 et je voudrais
connaître l'état des recommandations que
vous avez fait et si elles ont été
d'ores et déjà reçus suivi ou corrigé
par l'établissement c'est un
établissement qui tient beaucoup à coeur
par la qualité de ses professionnels et
des gens qui qui travaillent voilà pour
cette longue introduction avant que mes
collègues ne vous interroge à leur tour
vous avez la parole madame la contrôleur
général
merci monsieur le Président
merci de m'avoir invité de nous avoir
invité
c'est un peu émouvant d'habitude moi je
suis là-bas et je prends des notes je
sais pas si je manque d'habitude dans
l'exercice mais bon
que vous dire les prisons j'en parlerai
en dernier parce que
malgré les petits compliments que vous
avez glissé sur Fresnes je pense pas que
ce soit non on est très loin de l'idylle
c'est un endroit dont même le directeur
de la pénitentiaire dit que c'est une
verrue qu'il faudrait raser tellement
c'est franchement c'est ignoble
la dernière lettre que j'ai reçue de
Fresnes c'est un monsieur qui crie
au secours j'ai j apostrophe est des
cafards partout venez
franchement c'est atroce nos collègues
mes collègues qui visitent ces
établissements 15 jours par mois
franchement prennent en pleine figure 15
jours par mois une violence
très dure à encaisser parce que quand
m'a dit je vais être trivial quand une
de mes collègues m'a dit j'en suis au
troisième gars qui me dit
je ne peux pas chier
parce que dans la cellule on est trois
donc j'attends que mes codes détenus
partent en promenade donc je ne vais
plus en promenade
un autre lui a dit
nous-même a écrit je mange de moins en
moins parce que comme ça j'ai vécu moins
et d'autres qui vous disent ben j'ai des
problèmes graves parce que je n'y arrive
plus donc c'est quand même
quand on pense qu'à à la prison de
Toulouse Seysses un détenu à attraper la
leptospirose c'est-à-dire la maladie de
l'urine de rat parce que il a ramassé
étant indigent il a ramassé dans la cour
des mégots pour fumer
on est quand même obligé de se poser
quelques questions sur sur notre société
sans employer de grands mots c'est
vraiment
ce sont des endroits terrifiants bon les
prisons les maisons d'arrêt je veux dire
puisque la surpopulation
il existe que dans les maisons d'arrêt
donc
la dernière
qu'on a vu par exemple si je parle de la
des
[Musique]
finalement j'ai dit que je terminerai
sur le pesant je commence c'est pas
grave
la dernière que j'ai vu la commission de
sécurité a donné son accord pour un avis
favorable à la continuité de
l'exploitation mais en se basant sur le
nombre théorique de place et non sur le
nombre d'habitants de la prison une
prison dans laquelle il y a pas de
plaque chauffante parce que
l'électricité le système électrique ne
le permet pas et donc les détenus se
chauffent leur
café ce qu'ils sont à cuire sur ce qu'on
appelle des chauffettes c'est à dire
quatre tubes de concentré de tomates
vidées dans laquelle ils enroulent un
mouchoir
il pose une casserole sur 4 boîtes de
conserve ils mettent le feu à l'huile
et bon il faut trois quarts d'heure pour
chauffer sa dos et surtout vous entrez
dans la cellule c'est une odeur qui vous
prend à la gorge d'huile brûlée mais
surtout on se dit mais c'est pas
possible
ça va prendre feu c'est
et le feu le feu c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas rare quand on était à la
prison de Gradignan trois par cellules
je le rappelle il y a une cellule il y a
eu un incendie de cellules un incendie
volontaire on a retiré un mort et un
demi-mort si je peux dire parce que je
n'ai pas de ses nouvelles mais aux
dernières nouvelles il allait très très
mal donc
c'est ça la surpopulation la
surpopulation c'est aussi
on a une obligation de soins par exemple
et bien on ne peut pas la respecter on
peut pas la respecter parce qu'il faut
trois mois pour voir le psychiatre on a
un abcès dentaire on se perce les dents
soi-même parce qu'il faut il y a pas des
scores pour vous accompagner chez le
dentiste
je sais pas comment décrire mieux il n'y
a pas d'activité puisqu'il y a pas assez
d'activités pour tout le monde puisqu'il
y a trop de monde pour les activités il
tout est contraint le personnel parce
que on s'entretient énormément avec les
détenus mais énormément aussi avec le
personnel pénitentiaire les surveillants
la dernière fois que j'étais que j'y
étais et que j'étais en prison et très
peu de temps ils nous ont confié ils ont
dit nous on vit dans la détresse la plus
totale
à Gradignan
les surveillants nous ont dit moi
détenus je refuse de rentrer dans la
cellule
donc
et pourtant s'il détenus de rentrer
tellement stimulant et moi j'ai passé
des heures dans ces cellules à discuter
avec les détenus et je peux vous dire
c'est particulier moi j'étais juché sur
le frigidaire le réfrigérateur pardon on
avait installé une planche qui sert à
mettre le matelas au sol pour les
surélever un peu qui tient vous avez du
bien le voir pendant vos visites tout ça
c'est du brick et du broke
c'est dangereux c'est si ça prend feu on
tremble à l'idée que ça prenne feu parce
que si ça prend feu la nuit comme il y
avait par exemple à l'ouverture de
Toulouse c'est un surveillant pour 50
détenus on en est aujourd'hui à un
surveillante pour 140 détenus je sais
pas qui de nous accepterait de voir son
travail triplé comme ça mais ça n'est
pas possible ce n'est pas possible de
laisser et les détenus et les
surveillants dans cet état
tout ça pour vous dire que
on paye cher on paye 110 euros par jour
par détenus mais on paye 110 euros par
jour par détenus pour que les gens
ressortent de là pierre qui ne sont
entrés donc qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise c'est pas
économiquement ça ne tient pas non plus
si on fait ce calcul bête
évidemment quand on sort de trois mois
quatre mois là-dedans on se demande à
quoi ça a servi puisque si c'est pour
passer 22 heures sur 24 en cellule dans
les conditions que vous connaissez que
je viens de vous décrire
en pire état
au personnel de l'éducation nationale
sur laquelle j'attire votre attention
parce que bientôt on a rendez-vous avec
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
pour essayer de prôner un statut des
profs qui dépendent directement enfin
que l'éducation nationale s'implique
dans les prisons autrement par des
conventions de façon plus pérenne
parce que savez-vous que
les professeurs en prison ont les mêmes
vacances que les professeurs à
l'extérieur ce qui fait que quand un
adolescent est incarcéré au quartier
mineur en juin et bien si en septembre
il a pas eu une heure de cours c'est un
peu stupide quand on pense que
la prison ne fonctionne pas sur le
rythme des vacances scolaires et ce
serait bien que l'éducation nationale
face à un effort pour s'impliquer comme
l'a fait la santé en prison il y a bien
longtemps
et parviennent
un statut peut-être plus attractif et
puis peut-être avec
je sais pas comment il ferait pour pour
que les vacances soient comprises dans
ces
plus ces vacances scolaires c'est bête
en prison ça n'a pas de sens les
vacances scolaires
puisqu'il y a pas de vacances
ensuite pour vous dire que nous je suis
pas dire nous militons mais nous prenons
fermement la régulation carcérale je
sais que c'est pas trop dans l'air du
temps mais
tant mieux je sais mais j'en suis bien
contente mais
je peux vous dire qu'on a eu le grand
plaisir d'accueillir au contrôle général
une trentaine d'organisations syndicales
des personnels pénitentielles des
personnes et pénitentielles des
magistrats des avocats des organisations
qui travaillent en prison toutes
les organisations qui peuvent rentrer en
prison et qui et qui travaillent
certaines à condamné les gens d'autres à
les en faire sortir et que tout à part
deux organisations
militent fermement pour pour la
régulation carcérale
enfin prône préconise son pour et ça a
été
une vraie moi j'avais un peu j'étais un
peu on était un peu anxieux avant mais
ça a été un vrai succès
on va disons qu'on a constitué à partir
de la groupe de travail qui avec donc
les syndicats de magistrats de directeur
de prison les surveillants viendront
plus tard parce qu'en ce moment ils sont
en pleine campagne électorale donc il
tenait pas tellement à venir à ce
moment-là mais enfin on a des rapports
très fréquents avec eux et ils viendront
plus tard quand les élections sont
passées
les organisations d'avocat
tous ceux qui travaillent en prison et
on s'est quitté sur le fait qu'on allait
se revoir en janvier
et on est en train de préparer le texte
qui
issue de ces de cette rencontre qui a
duré toute une journée et tous à peu
près 1000 litres pour prendre la
régulation carcérale parce que ça ne
peut pas durer comme ça de quelques
façons de quelques façons qu'on le
prenne de quelques je pense que de
quelques bords politiques que l'on soit
peu importe parce que ce qui compte
c'est même pas je dirais même pas ne
parlons même pas d'humanisme puisque
c'est devenu presque une insulte ni de
droits de l'homme puisqu'on se fait
traiter de droit de lomismes assez vite
mais parlons de même cyniquement voilà
quelqu'un rentre en prison il faut se
mettre dans la tête que
sauf à deux à quelques exceptions près
les détenus qui rentrent et bien ils en
sortiront et bien faisons en sorte
qu'ils en sortent le meilleur possible
c'est un calcul rien que économique pour
la société
un calcul rationnel pour la société et
donc voilà c'est je trouve vous savez
à Gradignan et à Seysses peut-être ce
problème sera
aborder et ça va me permettre de
basculer sur un autre chant qui est
celui je peux être trop longue descente
de rétention mais il y a un système que
les surveillants appellent les portes
tournantes c'est-à-dire c'est le trajet
de environ un volet de 500 étrangers qui
font le tour entre le la prison et le
centre de rétention
ils vont en centre de rétention et là
maintenant je bascule sur centre de
rétention mais ils vont en centre de
rétention par exemple il refuse le test
PCR il refuse d'augmenter dans l'avion
il retourne en prison ils prennent trois
mois de prison à la sortie de prison ils
vend dans le centre de rétention cela
est parfaitement assumé par le
gouvernement parce que ils ne tiennent
pas à ce que ces gens sortent du tout
et pour un prix que j'ose à peine de
qualifier d'énormes
et bien
la journée de rétention coûte un prix
dément alors que
malgré les efforts du gouvernement de ce
que j'ai entendu
un nombre infime des étrangers repas
faut se poser des questions là-dessus
et c'est pas qui ne repartent pas parce
que non pas parce que le gouvernement ne
fait de multiplie pas les efforts
diplomatiques pour les faire réaccepter
par les pays d'accueil mais les pays
d'accueil ne sont pas dingue pourquoi
ils reprendraient ces gens-là pourquoi
il les reprendra en tout cas il les
refusent puis ça a obéit aussi à des
logiques diplomatiques
qui nous échappe
et donc on voit mal l'intérêt de la
rétention et ce qu'on ferait pas mieux
enfin bon c'est un autre sujet en tout
cas en rétention on ne trouve plus que
une majorité de sortes de prison
d'ailleurs la dernière fois que je suis
allée en rétention il y a des gars qui
s'accrochent à moi il me disaient une
dame faites quelque chose vous voulez
pas me faire retourner en prison la
détention c'était le paradis à côté de
la rétention
c'est dire parce que c'est un univers
extrêmement carcéral la rétention
et puis disons qu'il y a peu
s'il y a peu d'empathie de la part de
certaines franges
d'entre nous d'entre nous les citoyens
pour les prisonniers disons qu'il y en a
encore moins pour les étrangers en
centre de rétention et
je ne sais pas
comment vous dire que
c'était descente qui était prévu pour 15
jours
on y passe maintenant 90 jours
c'est un peu
l'enfer quand même ils ont pas tort les
gars qu'on voit là-dedans et pendant le
covid c'était une vision d'horreur parce
que on était tous masqués et on entrait
dans des salles communes ou on trouvait
50 types qui se frôlaient ce
fréquentaient parlait et se refiler le
virus
il y a et je comprends pas la base
légale de la rétention même est en cause
puisque
vous savez que les étrangers doivent y
être tenus le temps strictement
nécessaire à leur éloignement mais il
n'y a pas d'éloignement
très très peu d'éloignement
donc voilà c'est une question qui reste
posée qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour résoudre
ce problème
est-ce qu'on devrait pas intégrer les
étrangers qui travaillent qui qui payent
des impôts chez doux et qui sont les
plus faciles à attraper les plus faciles
à renvoyer
c'est ça qui est regrettable c'est
peut-être je ne sais pas enfin bon on en
reparlera certainement
je peux vous parler des centres
éducatifs fermés
qui est l'antige qui sont les antichards
de la prison j'aurais mieux fait de
commencer par ça avant les centres de
rétention mais comme j'étais sur les
enfin bon bref c'est pas grave
les centres éducatifs fermés ce sont des
structures très préoccupantes je vous le
dis parce que on y trouve le meilleur
comme le pire et quand c'est le pire je
peux vous dire qu'on a eu une expérience
cuisante n'est-ce pas Andrée il y a peu
on nous a fait visiter un centre
transformer extraordinaire on avait fait
un rapport catastrophique sur ce centre
on nous a invité un an plus tard à
visiter comme il avait changé tu me
frappes ah non
j'ai cru qu'il me disait ne dit rien
et en plus il y a un avantage c'est que
devant la commission des lois on peut
tout dire puisque vous avez ici devant
vous les reprend le temps de la nation
donc c'est une expérience
on nous invite donc un an plus tard
avoir
à quel point la directrice était démenée
pour changer tout suivre toutes nos
recommandations et on arrive dans un
endroit
idyllique on déjeune avec les gamins il
nous avait préparé le déjeuner c'était
formidable il y avait même une salle de
détente avec un petit Bouddha de l'eau
qui fait du goutte à goutte des enfants
enfin d'endroit qui me fichent les
jetons moi mais disons que c'était
c'était quand même c'était l'endroit
relax c'était merveilleux on sort de la
enchantée 4 jours plus tard je reçois un
syndicat de la PJJ qui me dit vous êtes
fait avoir parce que le centre il va
fermer et qu'est-ce qu'on apprend cette
directrice merveilleuse elle avait une
relation sexuelle avec un des enfants et
le centre a fermé et je me suis dit là
mais c'est
tout juste horrible
et donc et donc voilà
j'ai vu la directrice de la PJJ qui m'a
dit mais j'ai honte je suis morte de
honte c'est affreux bon mais on a
rencontré il y a moins paroxystique il y
a des endroits qui sont absolument
géniaux où il y a des il y a des il y a
des activités mais moi j'ai visité un
centre et là sans blaguer vraiment
formidable où les gamins étaient heureux
il y avait pas de mur il se barrait pas
c'est la première fois je me suis dit
mais c'est incroyable je vais me dire
tiens je mets à bas tous mes présupposés
et je me dis c'est dommage que ces
enfants restent pas plus longtemps dans
ce sens tellement il est bien il y avait
des ateliers du bois des ateliers du
métal il y avait un atelier cuisine et
puis surtout le centre avait lié des
relations avec la ville la petite ville
qui était à côté il servait les repas à
la maison de retraite les enfants non
mais ça fait il leur fabriquer des
tables des chaises des qu'il y avait
un événement il
préparait le buffet enfin bon et puis il
y a des endroits qui sont abominables
des sève qui sont à fermer
voilà donc je suis ennuyé que le
gouvernement prévoit de multiplier leur
leur construction ou leur création parce
que souvent on en construit pas mais on
en crée
parce que je crois que le modèle n'est
pas du tout stabilisé
et puis pour ne pas être trop long je
vais passer la parole à André faire une
sur les sur les établissements
psychiatriques ce qui est très fort sur
le sujet
merci
donc sur les établissements de santé
mental
nous avons
poursuivi les constats qu'on faisait au
cours des années antérieures sur les
puisque c'est un domaine dans lequel peu
de choses a changé elle exception d'une
évolution le système dont je vous
reparlerai le principaux constat sur ces
établissements
c'est d'abord une nutrition progressive
mais de plus en plus grave depuis la
crise sanitaire du nombre des
psychiatres et du nombre des soignants
c'est-à-dire une véritable perte de
moyens des établissements de santé
mentale qui se traduit dans un grand
nombre d'établissements dans un
mouvement qui s'est amorcé en 2021 et
poursuivi en 2022 par des fermetures de
lit parfois des fermetures de lit en
nombre important et des fermetures de
lit dont on nous dit qu'elles sont
provisoires mais dont la réalité des
entretiens que nous avons avec les
directeurs d'établissements montrent
qu'elles sont provisoires mais sans
perspective de sans perspective de faim
de ce point de vue plusieurs sujets sont
en cause notamment la démographie
médicale en premier lieu quelquefois
mais de manière plus marginale des
questions de moyens parce que ce qui
manque véritablement dans les
établissements ce n'est pas le droit de
recruter ce ne sont pas les ressources
permettant de recruter c'est simplement
la ressource humaine elle-même
c'est-à-dire le manque de candidat pour
les emplois que ce soit par manque
d'attractivité des emplois ou simplement
par manque de personnes formées alors ça
quelques conséquences graves sur les
droits des patients
la première c'est que évidemment comme
la crise doit être toujours prise en
charge
la psychiatrie allège sa présence sur
les structures ouvertes et les moyens de
prévention ce qui a pour effet
d'augmenter le nombre des crises puisque
on a allégé la prévention
une augmentation du nombre des crises
conduit directement à une augmentation
du nombre des patients pris en soins
sans consentement et cette augmentation
est d'ailleurs facilité par le droit
puisque depuis les lois de 2011 et 2013
des procédures allégées de placement
soit sans consentement ont été institués
et ce sont ces sur ces procédures
allégées et exclusivement sur ses
procédures allégées que se fait la
croissance très importante du nombre des
placements en soins sans consentement de
sorte que ça nous conduit à dire que
l'allègement des procédures n'est pas
forcément qu'une bonne chose dans la
mesure où il facilite aussi l'adoption
de mesure de contraintes dans ce
contexte les établissements que nous
visitons sont dans des conditions
matérielles dont le moins qu'on puisse
dire et qu'elles sont très variables
très souvent les conditions matérielles
de la psychiatrie sont quand même
globalement plus satisfaisante que celle
des prisons il reste quelques quelques
hébergements en chambre hôtelière sans
sanitaire mais c'est tant à être de plus
en plus rare la question des chambres
partagées est également de plus en plus
rare et l'exiguité des établissements
psychiatriques est un problème qui ne se
pose vraiment que dans les
établissements de centre-ville à
singulièrement dans certains secteurs de
psychiatrie de Paris mais dans les
établissements de centre-ville ou dans
les secteurs de psychiatrie implantés
dans des hôpitaux généraux à partir du
moment où on a des établissements
spécialisés en psychiatrie généralement
les infrastructures sont correctement
organisées le troisième constat général
qu'on fait nos établissements de santé
mentale c'est encore une certaine
réticence à l'entrée du droit dans la
psychiatrie entrée du droit qui entre
avec qui qui est difficile sous deux
aspects premier aspect c'est celui de
l'information des patients très souvent
les patients sont informés sur leurs
droits dans leur situation sur leur
droit de recours sur le mode de vie par
des soignants et des soignants d'un
grand mal à faire ça de ne pas parce
qu'ils ne sont pas formés d'autre part
parce qu'ils comprennent avec beaucoup
de difficultés pourquoi ils auraient à
expliquer à des patients comment se
prémunir contre l'action de gens qui ne
veulent que leur bien et c'est quelque
chose c'est on place les soignants
devant une injonction paradoxale qu'il
ne faut pas négliger parce que
c'est très difficile pour un infirmier
qui prend en charge impatient de lui
dire voilà comment tu vas pouvoir te
protéger contre moi
c'est un exercice compliqué la deuxième
exercice compliqué et là j'en viens une
réforme législative de
2022 c'est la question de l'entrée du
droit par la voie juridictionnelle
depuis 2016 le droit était entré dans le
contrôle des mesures le juge était entré
dans le contrôle des mesures de
placement soit son consentement pardon
depuis 2013 depuis
2022 à la suite de vestissitudes dont
vous avez je pense le souvenir devant le
Conseil constitutionnel le gouvernement
a dû mettre en place un contrôle
juridictionnel des mesures d'isolement
et de contention c'est un contrôle qui
aujourd'hui se heurte à des difficultés
pratiques importantes la première étant
d'ailleurs la convergence des systèmes
d'information entre l'hôpital et la
juridiction puisque les délais
d'intervention de jeux sont extrêmement
courts donc l'intervention du juge n'est
possible dans les délais prévus par la
loi que s'il existe un flux
d'information en temps réel
plus d'informations très souvent
n'existe pas ou existe mal donc il y a
vraiment ce problème de convergence de
circuit d'information qui est un
problème très important sans lequel se
recourt
ne pourra pas entrer dans les faits ne
sera pas possible de le mettre en place
en second lieu évidemment cette
difficulté
s'étend la question de l'agenda du
personnel et ce que je vous disais sur
la démographie médicale sur la
démographie infirmière en psychiatrie
plus la situation que nous connaissons
sur l'état de saturation des
juridictions fait que ce nouveau recours
a été vécu une part et d'autre comme une
charge de travail supplémentaire et donc
et pour le moment
culturellement rejeté je dirais de part
et d'autre je veux dire par là que les
psychiatres se demandent pourquoi on les
a on les encombre de ce recours et les
juges se demandent encore un peu ce
qu'ils ont à juger quand quand on les
saisit sur ce point
néanmoins le CGLPL qui a été depuis
longtemps promoteur de ce contrôle
juridictionnel de l'isolement et de la
contention qui reste encore promoteur de
l'extension du contrôle juridictionnel à
quelques mesures qui lui échappent en
psychiatrie notamment le placement en
unité pour maladie difficiles ne peut
que souligner qu'il est nécessaire que
ce contrôle existe soit renforcé et que
ce contrôle juridictionnel soit
réellement vivant ce qui pour le moment
semble entrer dans les faits avec
beaucoup de difficultés
pour conclure je voudrais puisque j'ai
la parole répondre aux questions que
poser monsieur le Président Houlier sur
le suivi des recommandations Bédenac et
le centre hospitalier Labori
globalement sur le suivi des
recommandations
il faut savoir que les recommandations
de CGLPL sont très nombreuses si les uns
ou les autres d'entre vous ont lu un
rapport vous pouvez voir dans dans un de
nos rapports de visite les visites étant
longues nous voyons les établissements
dans le détail et il n'est pas rare que
des rapports comprennent plus de 50
recommandations donc le suivi de nos
recommandations est un exercice que nous
ne faisons pas de nous-mêmes c'est un
exercice que nous faisons de manière
déclarative en interrogeant le
gouvernement donc les chiffres que je
vais vous donner sont à prendre avec la
précaution qui s'impose parce que quand
nous retournons dans les établissements
c'est-à-dire le suivi des
recommandations déclaratifs fait au bout
de trois ans quand nous retournons dans
les établissements c'est dans un délai
beaucoup plus long puisque nous faisons
beaucoup de visites mais pas assez pour
y aller tous les trois ans non plus et
donc pour le suivi
de ces recommandations en gros suivant
ça varie suivant qu'on est en
psychiatrie en prison ou en rétention
administrative mais il y a plus d'un
tiers de nos recommandations qui sont
déclarés suivis des faits environ un
cinquième c'est à dire un peu moins de
20% qui sont déclarés sans suite et
le reste c'est à dire à peu près 40 %
aussi qui sont déclarés partiellement
suivi alors on est vraiment dans du
déclaratif pour nous l'ambition que nous
avons derrière ce suivi des
recommandations ce n'est pas tellement
de connaître des chiffres ce n'est même
pas tellement devoir progresser ces
chiffres parce que nous ne sommes pas
tout à fait certains de la vérité qui
est derrière mais notre ambition réelle
c'est de faire en sorte que les services
de contrôle interne de l'administration
c'est à dire l'inspection générale de la
justice la mission de contrôle interne
de la pénitentiaire les inspections des
agences régionales de santé l'inspection
générale de la police intègre
recommandations et intègre le suivi de
nos recommandations au suivi qu'ils font
de leur propre recommandations quand ils
vont dans les établissements c'est à
dire que notre ambition première c'est
de faire en sorte que nos
recommandations entre dans les
référentiels de contrôle interne des
administrations et ceci je dois dire
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne assez
bien
pour le coup quand nous faisons des
recommandations en urgence nous nous
comptons pas en principe d'un suivi
déclaratif nous retournons voir sur
place sur bedonnax ça n'a pas encore été
fait ça va l'être les recommandations en
urgence de Bédenac doivent avoir à peu
près 18 mois le cas de Bédenac était un
cas très particulier puisque c'est un
cas une situation d'un centre de
détention dans lequel il y a des
patients des détenus qui sont également
des patients dépendants qui pour des
raisons judiciaires ou pour des raisons
de difficultés de placement de sortie ne
sont pas de bénéficient pas de
suspension de peine pour raison médicale
et reste à la charge de l'administration
pénitentiaire qui je le dis avec
insistance n'est pas organisée pour
prendre en charge des patients
dépendants et donc l'administration
pénitentiaire avait donné a fait ce
qu'elle a pu assez bien
mais toute seule
c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'a pas eu le
soutien des deux institutions qui
auraient dû la soutenir d'une part le
système sanitaire d'autre part l'aide
sociale qui relève du département et
donc nous avons trouvé des patients
grabataires parfois en situation
d'obésité très grave que
l'administration pénitentiaire n'était
pas en mesure tout simplement de sortir
de leur lit y compris quand ils étaient
souillés donc c'est une situation
extrêmement grave et c'est une un
établissement dans lequel nous sommes
maintenant à moins de deux ans de la
visite mais nous allons prochainement
retourner pour voir pour constater
nous-mêmes ce qui a été fait comme nous
le faisons habituellement quand nous le
faisons des recommandations en urgence
en ce qui concerne le centre hospitalier
laboriste c'est une situation tout à
fait différente c'est d'abord c'est une
c'est un état une visite que nous avons
fait très récemment puisqu'elle date du
mois de juin ce qui veut dire que
l'établissement n'a pas encore reçu le
rapport provisoire que nous lui
adresserons au titre de la procédure
contradictoire donc je peux pas
dire ici ce qui sera dans ce rapport qui
n'est pas fini en revanche je peux faire
état des premières impressions que
l'équipe que l'équipe a retiré de cette
de cette visite le centre hospitalier
Labori est un établissement
psychiatrique que je qualifierais d'un
peu comme un autre plus tôt un peu mieux
qu'un autre pas c'est un établissement
dans lequel on rencontre les difficultés
à ses habituelles que l'on rencontre en
psychiatrie
c'est un établissement qui bénéficie de
la présence d'une université avec des
professeurs d'université donc très capé
à sa tête donc c'est un établissement
que plutôt bien tenu dans lequel les
droits des patients sont respectés même
si la prise en compte de la dimension
juridique de la prise en charge n'est
pas toujours n'est pas toujours optimale
mais enfin les rarement donc il y a des
recommandé il y aura des recommandations
je pense là-dessus des recommandations
également sur le mode de calcul et la
politique de réduction du recours à
l'isolement et de la contention mais en
tout cas ne vont pas dans cet
établissement que je sache et sous
réserve de ce qui sera dans le rapport
provisoire relever d'atteinte grave au
d'atteindre grave au droit des patients
pris en charge
lors de son audition Daniel Simoneau est
aussi revenu sur la question de la
rétention de personnes en situation
irrégulière certains étrangers
expliquent-elles passent ainsi du centre
de rétention à la prison et de la prison
au centre de rétention un système que
les surveillants appellent les portes
tournantes extraits
je voulais tout d'abord vous remercier
pour le travail que vous avez accompli
que vous continuez d'accomplir et qui
nous donne une vision particulièrement
claire même si elle était effrayante la
plupart du temps des conditions de
détention et de rétention ma question
concerne plus particulièrement
donc elle concerne les outre-mer et
notamment le centre les centres de
rétention administrative de la Réunion
et de Mayotte où les conditions sont
particulièrement indignes
Mayotte et la concentre plus de la
moitié des des retenus de France dans
des conditions qui ont été dénoncées il
y a plusieurs reprises par vous mais
également par par d'autres associations
La Cimade notamment à la Réunion on a un
centre de rétention qui ne compte que si
place et nous sommes confrontés de par
notre positionnement géographique avec
Mayotte un nombre important de personnes
retenues on a depuis quelques mois
maintenant un phénomène nouveau avec des
vagues migratoires venus du Sri Lanka et
qui rendent des conditions de rétention
encore plus indignes parce que dans avec
6 places on ne peut pas recevoir les
gens dans des conditions correctes alors
je ne suis pas favorable bien évidemment
à ce que l'on crée de nouveaux centres
de rétention à ce que l'on les augmente
ou nous avaient donné quelques pistes
mais ça crée des situations qui sont
particulièrement inquiétantes
on a été alerté rien que cette année en
février 2022 on a eu un homme qui a été
qui a passé 10 jours en sorte de
rétention sans pouvoir voir un juge on a
au mois de mai un français qui a été
enfermé en centre de rétention et qui
n'a pu être libéré de tardivement et au
mois de septembre des Sri Lankais
numérotés en centre de rétention je
voulais avoir vos préconisations sur
cette situation inquiétante monsieur
Jean-Philippe
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
contrôleur bonjour Merci pour votre
exposé et pour le travail que vous
réalisez en ce qui me concerne ma
question sera précise
le 2 mars dernier mot de passe en savoir
qu'il s'est passé un drame important
dans la centrale d'Arles puisque un
détenu donc radicalisés apportés
atteinte à Yvan Cologne et que suite au
coma celui-ci est décédé cela est créé
beaucoup des mois en Corse mais pas
simplement y compris au sein de cette
commission des lois
donc à ce stade je voulais simplement et
de manière très très simple savoir
savoir un petit peu votre vision et
votre votre vision votre point de vue
sur sur la gestion du parcours du détenu
en question puisque beaucoup d'arguments
ont été exposés devant cette commission
pour justifier le fait que se détenus ne
puisse pas aller en guerre en quartier
d'évaluation de la radicalisation
mais aussi mais aussi plus globalement
sur la gestion du statut de de détenus
particulièrement surveillés de manière
générale et en particulier dans dans ce
cas là votre point de vue est important
dans la mesure où prochainement il y
aura très certainement comme si on
enquête parlementaire qui qui se
penchera sur sur ce qui s'est passé donc
merci pour vos réponses par avance
merci Madame la contrôleur général pour
vos réponses à ses premières questions
alors j'y réponds d'abord à Caroline
Abadie je crois
et bien effectivement il y a des efforts
faits sur le budget il y a des efforts
qui portent sur de nouvelles places de
prison bien que
j'aimerais bien que quelqu'un un jour
m'explique
ce que sont ces 15000 places de prison
promise de mandatures présidentielles en
mandature présidentielle
je j'avoue que j'ai du mal à m'y
retrouver c'est toujours 15000 places
qu'on nous annonce et c'est jamais que
15000 places auxquelles on aboutit donc
je crois que les présidents successifs
reprennent les 15000 places du précédent
et puis l'améliore de 2000 places et
puis enfin je veux juste signaler que la
prison de Lutterbach qui a ouvert il y a
à peu près il y a un peu moins d'un an
avait été annoncé en 2008 ou 2009 par
Michel Alliot-Marie donc il faut très
longtemps pour faire sortir une prison
de terre je ne pense pas que ce soit la
solution si on cherche des solutions
rapides disons enfin un peu plus rapide
que ça plus rapide que 10 ans j'ai été
un peu choquée de la réponse du ministre
de la Justice sur nos constats à la
prison de Gradignan surpeuplés à 245%
et qui
nous dit c'est pas grave parce que dans
deux ans une partie de nouvelles maisons
d'arrêt sortira de terre et dans 4 ans
une autre mais c'est maintenant qu'il
faudrait améliorer les choses et j'en
profite voilà et quant à la réinsertion
en détention et l'importance des
formations elle est énorme et c'est pour
ça que c'est pour ça que on souhaite un
ce mécanisme de régulation carcérale
afin que que
les gens est accès à la formation est
accès le but n'est pas la vengeance
immédiate moi je comprends très bien
qu'on veuille se venger si quelqu'un me
fait du mal j'ai une envie
c'est de lui mettre peut-être mon point
sur la figure ou pire oui c'est humain
ça mais heureusement il y a un truc qui
s'appelle la justice et qui fait que ça
n'est pas le Far West voilà
oui je ne connais pas Baba
malheureusement je vois qu'il y a deux
qui vous parlent mais je ne connais pas
personnellement
j'en parlerai à Baba si je le rencontre
et en tout cas
non d'accord en tout cas moi je vous
rejoins totalement sur la ré la
prison marche sur deux jambes l'une qui
punit
et l'autre qui réinsère et c'est
là-dessus que doivent porter nos efforts
parce que une peine de prison ne peut se
contenter d'être une vengeance ou une
punition elle doit aussi préparer les
gens à devenir un peu meilleur et ça
n'est pas être gauchiste que de dire ça
c'est peut-être être réaliste puisque
ben oui non je répondais à Madame du
rassemblement national
qui m'a dit que je surfais sur l'esprit
gauchiste 68 armes disons que j'ai
évolué depuis l'esprit gaucher 68 tard
j'ai beaucoup vieilli depuis l'esprit
gaucher 68 tard
mûri si vous merci c'est gentil enfin
mûri et j'en profite pour parler de mon
salaire j'ai jamais gagné autant
d'argent de ma vie c'est vrai ce n'est
pas 12000 euros c'est 10000 ce qui est
déjà énorme je le je le concède mais
je travaille énormément donc je sais pas
quoi dire
je n'allais pas non plus aller demander
une baisse de mon salaire voilà
et
créer des places de prison je crois que
j'ai répondu à votre question c'est très
certes peut-être
moi je suis pas pour vous êtes pour bon
ce sont deux conceptions qui
s'affrontent mais de toute façon vous ne
trouverez pas la solution immédiate ça
n'est pas la solution demain vous ne
verrez pas surgir il faut 10 ans
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'élus qui prônent
il faut du temps beaucoup de temps
beaucoup d'élus qui prônent la
construction de places de prison sont
contre la construction des places de
prison sur leur circonscription et
voilà et
quand je suis parti du Canard Enchaîné
j'avais haut comme ça de recours
d'élus et de résidents et de citoyens
contre la construction d'une prison
voilà vous parlez de prolifération des
portables en prison certes elle existe
elle existe de même que la prolifération
de la drogue en prison existe et de même
que cela sert parce que vous savez quand
on a fait cette réunion
au siège du contrôle général on était
assez fiers de réunir des gens qui ne se
parlent en général jamais moi j'ai
beaucoup de dialogues avec les
organisations syndicales de surveillants
mais il le reconnaisse qu'est-ce que
vous voulez oui le shit circule en
prison mais le shit sert aussi à calmer
les portables circulent en prison ça
sert aussi à calmer et il s'agit d'une
grande hypocrisie puisque plus tard on
parlera de l'internet c'est que certains
ont accès à l'internet beaucoup nous
appellent de leur portables et d'autres
n'ont pas accès il faut regarder la
réalité en face les choses ne sont pas
incantatoire
voilà moi aussi j'aimerais beaucoup que
les gens soient impars et je crois qu'on
le voudrait tous et que et que les
prisons soient exemples de rate cafard
depuis naisses de lit et qu'on puisse y
être soigné qu'on puisse y apprendre des
choses au lieu de ne rien y apprendre et
avouer que c'est quand même du temps
perdu du temps gâché et qui nous coûte
très cher
les mécanismes de régulation carcérale
pour répondre à Hugo bernalicis et bien
on peut les envisager de différentes
façons
il y a le modèle des ordonnances du
covid
rapide et bien fait il y a le numerus
clausus je crois que ça pose certaines
questions et que on trouvera plus de
gens qui sont contre que de gens qui
sont pour
et parmi les gens qui qu'on a réuni
l'autre jour il y a énormément de
questions qui sont posées des gens qui
sont plutôt très gauchistes ça va vous
surprendre qui n'était pas pour
pardon
non pas du tout ça me préoccupe je le
dis comme ça parce que je trouve ça
marrant
et des gens et des gens qui sont pas du
tout gauchistes et qui sont pour donc on
trouve de tout et les gens qu'on a réuni
c'est des gens qui ne se parlent jamais
d'habitude et qui se sont trouvés
d'accord sur des positions de principes
que sont oui ça ne peut pas durer donc
il faut qu'on trouve une solution pour
que les choses
s'améliorent
l'accès internet je laisserai André
ferraille vous en parler la polémique du
carte à Fresnes oui je l'ai trouvé
singulièrement triste parce que tout le
monde s'est bien poussé des hurlements
moi j'ai vu que pour une fois les
détenus et les surveillants
étaient ensemble
et que
il jouait à des jeux qui n'étaient pas
que la piscine enfin ce qu'on a appelé
pompeusement la piscine qui était un
gros bac
et les deux tours de cartes il y a deux
détenus qui ont fait des tours de cartes
j'avoue que c'était surprenant comme
image mais moi je les ai trouvés plutôt
sympathiques et surtout les surveillants
et les détenus avaient l'air content
d'être ensemble et et n'oubliez pas
qu'après il regagnait pour les uns leurs
coursifs pourris et pour les autres
leurs cellules pourries à trois dedans
voilà
le téléphone
améliorer les choses quand il n'est pas
monsieur bernalicis rongé par les
cafards parce que j'ai et alors j'ai
appris à l'occasion de ma dernière
visite à Gradignan j'ignorais que les
cafards étaient des bestioles en plus
d'être désagréable très dangereuse pour
la santé je savais pas que ça filait des
maladies terribles et je savais pas non
plus que comme les souris elle grignote
ou les lapins ils grignotent les fils du
téléphone donc ils sont fort friands je
sais pas pourquoi et donc il y a
beaucoup de fils de téléphone abîmés
actuellement et je rappelle également
que oui il y a une certaine hypocrisie à
savoir que les les téléphones
prolifèrent en détention et que
et qu'il n'y a pas d'accès Internet
alors
Monsieur
Eric
voilà posez merci vous n'êtes pas pour
la régulation
certes voilà j'en prends acte mais on
peut pas être tous d'accord n'est-ce pas
tous d'accord
heureusement que tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord avec tout le monde sinon ce
serait très ennuyeux
alors les centres de rétention
vous savez qui nous coûte énormément
cher je sais pas comment manier le
chiffre d'ailleurs que j'ai relevé de la
Cour des comptes sur le coup d'une
journée ensemble de rétention
tellement il m'a paru
hors du commun
moi je pense que oui plus de moyens
certainement que le bracelet
électronique c'est une solution très
intelligente
de même que l'assignation résidence est
une
est une solution très intelligente
plutôt que d'enfermer des gens qui
malheureusement
dans l'optique du gouvernement est dans
l'optique de la politique qui est
enclenché ne reparte pas
ça dépend pas
c'est oui vous le savez tous et toutes
ça dépend dans jeu diplomatique
quant à la
donc oui je trouve que c'est une
solution très bonne plutôt que
d'enfermer les gens là dedans
surtout que comme je vous le dis le
bracelet électronique coûtera infiniment
moins cher
quand je dis infiniment moins cher je
pèse mes mots c'est infiniment
infiniment moins cher
et que c'est quand même un souci
l'argent
quant à la rétention des mineurs bien
sûr
elle est indigne elle est quand on voit
ces images heureusement en France on
enferme beaucoup moins de mineurs que
dans d'autres pays que aux États-Unis
par exemple mais c'est vrai que c'est
effrayant de voir ses enfants fermés
on a été condamné pour ça et
l'assignation résidence est comme le
bracelet électronique une bonne solution
et beaucoup moins coûteuse parce que il
faut pas oublier que tout ça c'est de
l'argent public
nous avons c'est vrai
dresser
une un tableau alarmant de nos visites
de la surpopulation moi
quand vous me parlez de loi sur la
régulation carcérale je crois que j'ai
un peu répondu moi je suis pas nous ne
sommes pas législateurs mais ce qui a
été formidable dans la réunion dont je
vous parlais l'autre jour c'est que des
gens qui ne se parlent pas qui ne sont
en général pas d'accord sur rien était
d'accord au moins sur le fait qu'il faut
absolument trouver une solution pour que
la prison pour le prix qu'on paye
servent au moins à quelque chose parce
que mettre trois mois six mois un an des
gens à l'écart de la société d'accord ça
protège certainement la société mais si
ces gens ressortent dans le même état
qui sont entrés franchement ça n'a servi
à rien
et calculer le prix que ça nous a coûté
à 110 euros jour
pour le don le nombre de mois qu'on y
passe franchement c'est un système un
peu ancestral
un peu je dirais un peu
non pas bête mais un peu oui comme un
système qui se court après qui qui
n'arrive pas à trouver la sortie au fond
les mesures sur le travail qui ont été
annoncés
c'est c'est extrêmement c'est un sujet
extrêmement compliqué le travail parce
que peut-être vous le savez il y a
énormément d'abord d'entreprises de luxe
moi j'étais très étonnée de visiter des
ateliers ou on emballe des produits
extrêmement luxueux bon il y a eu un
jour concessionnaire m'a dit alors moi
mon client là il est entré dans
l'atelier pour faire une petite visite
il a vu des crottes de rat à côté de ses
pots de crème il a dit
c'est pas possible je m'en vais moi
chaque fois que comme journaliste j'ai
visité des ateliers en m'a dit surtout
taisez-vous ne dites absolument pas ne
citer pas le nom des des sociétés qui
qui donnent du travail elles ne veulent
pas j'ai jamais su c'était à cause de
l'image ça renvoyait que des détenus en
balles des pots de crème
emballent des rouges à lèvres ou si
c'est parce qu'il y avait les crottes de
rat ou si c'est à cause du salaire que
touche les détenus je sais pas qu'est-ce
qui en tout cas ils ne veulent surtout
pas que mais ce que je sais c'est que
plus il y a de contraintes plus ces
entreprises menacent de s'en aller
notamment si on menace menace d'une
hausse de salaire ils disent ben s'en va
ce que je comprends pas c'est comment on
fait l'Allemagne
pour qui est 70% des détenus qui
travaillent dans les prisons allemandes
et seul 30% qui ne travaillent pas parce
qu'ils ne veulent ou ne peuvent pas et
que nous le ratio est inverse c'est 30%
des détenus qui travaillent
on augmente on était à 25
voilà
on va pas on va pas cracher sur même sur
les petits progrès
l'autre mère et Mayotte
c'est je sais que la situation était
épouvantable et nous allons nous y
rendre parce qu'il y a longtemps qu'on
n'est pas allé à Mayotte
effectivement
franchement
c'est une situation
j'ai mal au cœur de vous dire que on va
s'y rendre on va faire le même constat
que vous et je ne sais pas ce qui va se
passer après mais je sachez que on est à
vos côtés et préoccupé au combien de
de la situation à Mayotte à la Réunion
je sais pas mais à mon avis ça dépasse
les conditions d'hébergement les
conditions ça dépasse c'est des enjeux
qui tiennent à la pauvreté du Sri Lanka
au chaos politique
à l'accueil des réfugiés politiques
quant à la mort horrible de Yvan Colonna
si vous voulez on en arrive à se dire
que
il se connaissaient moi vous savez on
nous a demandé de nous pencher de nous
saisir de cette enquête mais je pense
qu'il y a une enquête interne une
enquête judiciaire une enquête de
l'inspection générale de la justice je
crois que nous à quoi on servirait
là-dedans que à ce marché sur les pieds
les uns des autres le statut de DBS on
avait conçu comme une victoire que les
dps puissent enfin une victoire que les
dps puissent accéder à un travail puis
circuler je vais pas reculer là-dessus
c'est un drame
épouvantable j'ai pas d'autres mots pour
qualifier ça est-ce que ce type ne
devait pas se trouver là
j'attends ce que nous dira l'enquête
apparemment il y a eu quelques
défaillances
notamment dans la surveillance vidéo
mais c'est en fait l'habitude
de se dire c'est de là finalement il
s'entendait pas mal
il va en colonnaille et son assassin où
son meurtrier on verra ou un meurtre
il s'entendait pas mal alors je me
peut-être le surveillant c'est dit à
quoi bon les surveiller
l'enquête nous le dira et de toute façon
vu le choc et l'onde de chocs ça que ça
produit je pense que l'enquête on la
lira tous avec attention et moi je
on a déjà l'enquête générale de
l'inspection générale mais l'enquête
judiciaire ira plus loin j'imagine sur
les centres éducatifs fermés c'est une
question qui me préoccupait énormément
qui nous préoccupé énormément et j'ai
contente qu'elle vous préoccupe aussi
parce que vous avez dit que vous aviez
été choqué par mes propos
je crois que c'est monsieur riberotte
qui a dit ça
oui je crois mais
il faut pas vous méprendre comme je vous
ai dit on a visité des centres éducatifs
fermés qui justement sont absolument
formidables mais il faut bien avoir
conscience que le problème des centres
éducatif fermé et de plusieurs ordres
d'abord
on tombe sur des centres ou vous avez
beau me dire vous pouvez me dire il y a
26 TP pour 12 mineurs qui sont ces ETP
c'est le problème est là parce que il y
a des endroits où on a su construire et
et garder des équipes pérennes formées
solides qui savent répondre
à des gamins qui sont on le sait tous
pas facile du tout et même très
difficile même qui ont des problèmes
psychiatriques qui dépassent le centre
éducatif fermé mais
il y en a d'autres où les équipes
ne font que tourner il y a un turn-over
horrible il y a enfin horrible
sans cesse et plus personne ne veut
faire ce boulot il n'est pas attractif
moi j'ai noté dans celui dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure qui qui servait les
repas à la maison de retraite
fabriquaient des meubles pour la mairie
etc et où tout se passait bien j'ai noté
que l'équipe depuis 10 ans est
absolument pérenne et inchangé les gens
sont mieux formés mieux et mieux payés
il y a peut-être de ça aussi
qu'ailleurs en tout cas la direction a
fait en sorte de préserver son équipe et
il est vrai que ce ce sel pour moi c'est
c'était
le premier que j'ai visité et j'étais
mais ravi ravi malheureusement comme je
vous le disais on en a vu d'autres ou
c'était pas ça du tout donc
il faut il faut bien regarder ça en face
et se dire que oui un self c'est
certainement mieux que la prison mais je
pense que c'est pas mieux si c'est
n'importe quoi voyez on a vu par exemple
un centre éducatif fermé ou deux
éducateurs pendant le covid avait été
recruté parce que leur boîte de nuit
avait fermé ils sont dit tiens on va
faire du social ils ont été embauchés
dans le centre éducatif fermé
exact voilà donc il faut il faut une
équipe pérenne bien dirigée voilà il
faut que ce soit bien ensuite l'autre
problème c'est que les enfants et
adolescents qui arrivent dans les
centres éducatifs fermés ils ont un
passé vous savez que de façon assez
bizarre il n'existe pas d'études
longitudinale des jeunes
qui sont placés à l'ASE yeux parce qu'il
y a une majorité de gamins accueilli
dans les sèves qui viennent de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance que on ne s'épanou
ils viennent les éducateurs nous l'ont
dit moi je ne sais pas d'où il vient je
ne connais pas son passé et pire encore
je ne connais pas je ne connaîtrai pas
son avenir une fois qu'il sera parti
parce qu'il y a pas d'études après donc
comment savoir ce qui marche et ce qui
ne marche pas ça c'est un reproche qu'on
peut faire à la France un peu de c'est
ce manque de sérieux dans le dans le
suivi dans le dans le
dans l'évaluation des politiques
publiques
c'est dommage voilà autrement moi
comme je vous dis j'avais pas pour les
self une particulière appétence et quand
mais quand j'en ai visité j'ai changé
d'avis et je me suis dit mais oui quand
c'est un bon chef et bien ça peut être
formidable mais quand c'est mauvais ça
peut être épouvantable
comment
bien sûr mais là il s'agit d'enfants
et c'est moins fréquent là c'est
vraiment on passe du pire au meilleur et
quand c'est le pire je vous assure c'est
voilà donc alors sur les self il y avait
d'autres questions
[Musique]
oui je crois que j'ai répondu c'est
certain peut-être les mineurs y
arrivaient trop tardivement ça
je saurais pas vous répondre là-dessus
ce que je sais c'est que comme je vous
l'ai dit moi j'ai vu j'ai vu c'est
peut-être un peu vrai ce que vous dites
dans le CF formidable que j'ai visité il
y avait un gamin de 17 ans qui n'avait
plus de dents qui sucait son pouce et
qui dormait avec une tototte
et avant d'arriver dans ce sève il
vivait dans sa voix dans une voiture
avec ses parents donc je pense que oui
il est arrivé un peu tardivement dans le
système
social c'est sûr
j'arrivais pas à comprendre comment
personne s'était soucier
ni ses ni ses profs personne du sort de
cet enfant oui c'était parce qu'il était
un peu disons
pas dire enfin il était un peu différent
disons et et de voir arriver à l'école
au lycée au collège je ne sais pas un
gosse de 17 ans qui n'a plus de dents et
qui se sont tous je pense et qui a un
doudou en permanence et qui dort avec
une tétine je pense que
oui le problème aurait pu être détecté
avant et c'est tout le problème des
enfants de la zone parce qu'on parle
beaucoup du contrôle des EHPAD mais on
ne parle pas assez du contrôle
totalement défaillant des familles
d'accueil des foyers de l'enfance où je
vois que le sujet parce que moi c'est
pas notre compétence nous on les
récupère dans les centres éducatifs
fermés mais enfin il y a un énorme
problème de l'enfance en danger en
France et qui n'est pas du tout
pris parce que à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance comme ailleurs il y a une
désaffection pour ce métier c'est très
regrettable faudra peut-être les rendre
plus attractifs enfin il y a un problème
aussi de contrôle des endroits où on
envoie ses enfants où ils sont parfois
extraordinairement maltraités et
et c'est notre avenir et c'est nos
enfants à tous et c'est quand même
et c'est nos concitoyens bientôt donc il
va falloir qu'on
se penche sur le problème mais je vois
avec plaisir que le sujet commence à
émerger
excusez-moi sur la
sur la proportion en fait
parce que c'est une question qui m'a été
posée la proportion de sève qui marche
et qui marche pas
j'ai pas tellement d'idées puisque c'est
fluctuant voyez on a visité un sève qui
marchait extraordinairement bien
qui a marché comme ça trois mois jusqu'à
ce qu'on se rende compte qu'il y avait
un énorme problème avec la directrice
c'est je sais pas quoi vous dire je
est-ce que tu peux dire toi André je ne
peux pas répondre à la question de la
proportion que je peux dire c'est que
c'est des structures extrêmement
volatiles dans lesquels je dirais que
quand on va dans un CF comme ça
intuitivement on a une chance sur deux
pour que ce soit bon et une chance sur
deux pour que ce soit très mauvais
et c'est pas prévisible parce que un set
peut passer du tout autour en fonction
d'un changement d'équipe en fonction
d'un changement de pro des pédagogue
projet pédagogique
ou d'un changement de de portage
institutionnel notamment quand il passe
d'une association à un autre à une autre
en revanche il y a quand même quelques
sèves qui sont condamnés avant leur
naissance c'est ceux qui sont installés
n'importe où
ce que j'appelle n'importe où c'est dans
un dans un environnement qui n'est pas
du tout adapté et il y en a deux sortes
c'est à dire un environnement très un
espace très exigu dans un milieu très
urbanisé dans lequel il est pas possible
de séparer des enfants du milieu de
délinquance dont il sorte et l'autre
extrémité c'est-à-dire un sève qui est
installé au milieu de nulle part dans
lequel on a recrutera jamais d'éducateur
professionnel parce qu'il n'y en a pas
il y en a comme ça que nous avons fait
fermer deux fois qui se trouvent à la
limite du Puy-de-Dôme et de l'Allier
dans le Puy-de-Dôme
et
CEF ne pourra pas me semble-t-il il y a
deux ou trois ans qu'on y est pas allé
maintenant donc ça a peut-être changé
mais ne peut pas trouver une équipe
professionnelle sur place et non n'aura
pas
sur le rapport intimité mis à mal dans
les lieux de privation de liberté on ne
parlait pas que des prisons d'ailleurs
on parlait de tous les lieux qu'on
visite oui l'intimité mise à mal elle
est mise à mal en prison par la
surpopulation et bien sûr je
n'avons jamais dit que la prison était
censée être une vie légitaire et
d'ailleurs on en est très loin et j'ai
été fort étonné d'ailleurs
et fort inquiète quand j'ai entendu des
élus après l'histoire du karting à
Fresnes dire ah ben voilà c'est la
prison 4 étoiles c'est l'hôtel 4 étoiles
c'est
c'est la
vie légère de centre le Club Med
mais comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire je prie pour que ces élus n'ouvrent
jamais ni hôtel ni Club Med parce que
c'est une vision assez apocalyptique de
l'hôtel 4 étoiles mais bon
oui l'intimité est mise à mal que
l'intimité que l'intimité soit mise à
mal dans les lieux de privation de
liberté c'est un fait elle l'aide en
prison par la surpopulation je vois pas
qui d'entre nous supporterait d'être à
trois dans ces conditions dans une
cellule vous allez me dire on n'est pas
tous censés avoir comme idée délits qui
nous amène là j'en suis d'accord mais
j'en suis d'accord mais pour pour
réparer la société
je ne pense pas que ce soit bon
d'entasser les gens de cette façon la
privation de liberté
ça doit être la privation de liberté
c'est déjà la punie la punition c'est ça
et ensuite l'autre jambe comme quelqu'un
l'a dit très justement c'est la
réinsertion et la réinsertion ça passe
par l'apprentissage de quelque chose
d'autre par exemple quand on pense qu'il
y a 20% d'illettrés en prison c'est un
chiffre préoccupant sur notre école
la sécurité des surveillants mais nous
nous sommes parfaitement d'accord
d'ailleurs vous lirez dans nos rapports
à quel point nous nous entretenons
systématiquement avec tous les
surveillantes dont rencontrons nous
avons de longues conversations qui
soient des surveillants dégradés les
directions tout le monde et tous autant
qui sont
nous disent que ça n'est plus possible
ça n'est pas possible de les laisser
continuer à travailler dans ces
conditions c'est dangereux pour eux
c'est dangereux pourquoi parce que comme
nous ont dit les études Gradignan les
surveillants y sont violents ici mais
ils nous ont dit de façon très j'ai
trouvé très intelligente et très sensée
il sent violents on s'en prend plein la
figure mais faut les comprendre moi
j'avais jamais entendu ça faut les
comprendre on est trop ils deviennent
dingue il pète les plombs comme nous
parce que évidemment c'est les
surveillants et les détenus c'est des
hommes de 20 de très jeunes
bon assez costaud parfois assez bons qui
sont plein de vie restés enfermés 22h
sur 24 dans sa cellule sans autre
activité que s'énerver ensemble c'est
pas bon et pour les surveillants courir
moi je les ai vu mais dans la coursive
courir toi c'est la parloir toi c'est la
promenade attends non je me suis trompé
toi rentre toi sort toi va la douche toi
c'est infernal c'est un rythme infernal
et donc il y a d'ailleurs et il y a des
violences et je pense pas non plus que
ça fasse partie de la de la réinsertion
la violence qui vient de du fait que que
voilà ils sont tous finalement ils
subissent le même sort
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai répondu sur les 110
euros par jour à votre question et sur
la réinsertion parce que c'est vraiment
dommage c'est des occasions ratées parce
que il y a aussi des beaux exemples en
prison je pense à au fameux Berthé one
je sais pas si vous le connaissez
c'était un braqueur
qui dans le surveillant rentre dans sa
cellule il lui dit mais Berthet c'est
toi qui dessine ça mais je veux que tu
me dessines tu as de l'ordre dans les
mains Bertin et tous les jours le
surveillant revenait en disant Berthet
tu as fait mon dessin et Berthet se
moquait de lui et puis finalement il a
fait un dessin en décidant de
surveillant à genoux devant lui en
disant Berthet je t'en supplie un dessin
le dessin a fait le tour de la prison
tous les surveillants ont défilé devant
la la cellule de Berthet pour demander
un dessin aujourd'hui Berthet il a signé
avec le Journal de Mickey il est dehors
et il fait des bandes dessinées
sensationnelles sur la
donc
ça c'est un exemple oui formidable mais
il y en a d'autres bien sûr que tout le
monde ne sort pas en récidivant mais si
on pouvait ajouter ce plus qu'on que la
société doit pour ce prix là je trouve
c'est dépasser oui mais
dépasser la vengeance
dépasser la punition ok il y a la
punition mais la dépasser pour pour
apprendre des choses à ces gens les
remèdes dans les rails
d'une société normale
réapprendre à vivre ensemble à vivre
puisque de toute façon ils sortiront
donc c'est un mauvais calcul de pas
mettre le paquet sur la réinsertion en
prison
quant aux plats sont extérieur alors la
mille fois d'accord vous savez qu'il y a
un chiffre de 900
placements extérieurs par an en France
qui est absolument un chiffre en dessous
de je trouve en dessous de ce que ça
vraiment on devrait le multiplier le
placement extérieur j'imagine vous savez
tout ce que c'est
il y a les fermes de
d'Emmaüs qui accueillent les sortants de
prison
qui ont des reliquats de peine à
effectuer ils apprennent un métier ils
apprennent à vivre avec d'autres gens et
si ils s'en vont ils sont évadés ils
retournent en prison
et ça arrive ça arrive bon il y en a que
900 parce que elles ont beaucoup de mal
à survivre parce que figurez-vous que
elles sont mal financées par l'État
oui malheureusement le prix de journée
quand les fournisseurs de ces fermes
c'est la prison c'est l'état c'est les
magistrats etc c'est le Ministre bon
puisqu'on les fournit en prisonnier et
quand leur chambre ne sont pas remplies
elles ne sont pas financées donc ils
payent pour ces chambres qui ne sont pas
financées donc c'est idiot je vous
transmettrai si vous voulez
la note que j'ai reçue de citoyens et
justice sur ce sujet qui est très
intéressant de même que j'ai visité une
ferme de l'espoir dans l'Essonne qui est
un endroit
franchement bien où ils accueillent des
tiges il leur manque 100.000 euros pour
terminer l'année
c'est un peu dommage c'est un peu
dommage qui disparaissent alors que ils
font un boulot extraordinaire c'est une
ferme où il recueille des tas d'animaux
perdus abandonnés qu'on leur confie il y
a de tout comme animaux mais j'étais
passionnée j'aurais voulu rester là tout
le temps et et je crois que c'est bête
de voir des endroits qui marchent et qui
et qui périclite faute de
et ça je vous passerai aussi le
que vous alors la Talaudière
et bien nous allons dans nous nous
rendons dans les endroits quand par
routine parce que on se dit tiens il y a
longtemps qu'on n'est pas allé là ou
parce qu'on voit que l'endroit est
surpeuplé et ou alors quand on reçoit
beaucoup de lettres de signalement et en
ce haut là là il y a un truc qui va pas
on reçoit trop trop d'alerte et c'est
pour ça qu'on est allé à la Talaudière
les constats ne sont pas définitifs donc
ça m'ennuie de vous en faire part mais
je crois que c'est un endroit assez
compliqué
bien que alors la rénovation
moi
j'en avais entendu parler par des
professeurs qui
œuvrent à la Talaudière et qui m'ont dit
c'est atroce pour faire court on ne peut
plus faire court pratiquement parce que
on ne s'entend plus dans la tôle
tellement ça ça fait du bruit mais enfin
bon ce sera utile je voudrais dire que
de toute façon de rénovation il n'y aura
pas tant qu'il y aura tant de monde par
exemple on dépense beaucoup d'argent
on dépense beaucoup d'argent pour la
dératisation la désinfection mais vous
avez déjà eu des cafards chez vous
j'imagine ça est très bien que faut
vider les lieux quelques quelques heures
et là on ne peut pas vider les lieux du
tout donc à peine on a pu chuté les
cafards une fois que il reviennent trois
huit jours après les rats c'est pareil
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais compris quelque
chose je m'en ouvre à tous les
directeurs que je vois et à tous les
gradés à tous les surveillants pourquoi
on trouve alors vous savez les fenêtres
sont obstruées par des
des caillebotis dans lesquels les
détenus évidemment
font des trous pour continuer à se
passer des trucs et à jeter des choses
par les fenêtres moi je comprends pas
pourquoi on paye pas ce qu'on appelle
des oxy pour ramasser par terre ça
éviterait les rats jamais compris jamais
compris ça
voilà madame au Bono je pense que j'ai
répondu à vos questions sur les sève en
tout cas j'espère
la suppression
de ces instituts je ne sais pas quoi
vous en dire moi toujours pour qu'il y
ait des instituts qui produisent de la
de la de l'intelligence et des et des et
des statistiques c'est normal
mais cela dit le coût de la rétention
administrative je vous invite à vous
rapporter au
un rapport de l'accord des comptes celui
qui m'a fait sursauter
690 euros jour
alors
ça pose quand même un énorme problème on
en revient donc à l'assignation
résidence au bracelet électronique parce
que là ça va pas du tout c'est et comme
on était avec André ferraille il est
tombé sur ce chiffre en épluchant des
rapports sédiment enfin c'est pas
possible et donc on a demandé
confirmation spécialement aux deux
conseillères de la Cour des comptes qui
avaient fait le rapport et qui nous
l'ont confirmer donc voilà je vous
laisse vous êtes la représentation
nationale
je ne sais pas quoi faire de chiffres
parce que je sais bien qu'il y a un
double tranchant c'est la première fois
que je donne ce chiffre
j'espère vous en ferez bon usage je sais
pas quoi
je ne comprends pas comment ça peut
coûter si cher
oui
c'est un chiffre de la Cour des comptes
dont on a demandé
à demander confirmation
oui
voilà je sais pas quoi vous dire sur la
suppression de ces organismes moi j'aime
pas tellement qu'on supprime des
organismes qui fabriquent qui fabrique
des des statistiques
c'est dommage parce qu'il y en a pas
assez par exemple je vous parlais par
exemple s'il y a seulement il y avait
une étude sur les gamins qui arrivent
qu'on retrouve dans les centres
éducatifs fermés qui viennent de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et qu'on retrouve
plus tard sur les bancs des comparutions
immédiates
il y a quand même un énorme problème
pourquoi on met pas le paquet pour
réparer ses enfants d'ailleurs ces
enfants je suis d'accord ils n'ont pas
eu de chance au départ donnons-leur la
chance qui leur manque au lieu de les
coller dans des endroits quand vous
lisez les reportages et même les
constats qui sont faits actuellement sur
les foyers de l'enfance ça fait froid
dans le dos aucun nougne enverrait ses
enfants comment Canon ne laisserait ses
enfants être défendus dans les
conditions de la comparution immédiate
pour laquelle nous prenons également une
réforme puisque non seulement ça ne
diminue pas mais ça augmente et c'est
une procédure extrêmement pourvoyeuse de
prison euh où on peut prendre
5 ans que en très peu de temps sans
véritable instruction du dossier c'est
une procédure
au cours de laquelle je dis pas que
c'est pour ça qu'elle est morte pauvre
la paume c'est horrible mais c'est quand
même je sais pas il y a quelque chose de
l'ordre du symbole de voir qu'une
magistrate est morte en présence une
audience de comparution immédiate
j'espère avoir répondu à tout
ah mais non
pas du tout
pas du tout sur la première visite à
Fresnes il y a 5 ans et rien ne bouge je
rappelle écoutez je peux vous souhaiter
un autre exemple tout aussi choquant il
y a 20 ans il y avait ce formidable
rapport prison une humiliation pour la
République et qu'est-ce qui a bougé des
choses en bouger mais sur la
surpopulation rien ne bouge et
tant qu'on en sera là je pense que bien
sûr ça peut être désespérant de se dire
rien ne bouge des petites choses bougent
quand même
mais c'est vrai que c'est à la malle et
c'est vrai que c'est pas satisfaisant
quand au fait qu'il y a 6 fois plus de
suicide en prison
nous on a une standard
au contrôle général quand on a quelqu'un
au téléphone qui vous dit cette fois
c'est foutu une grosse voix
cave qui lui dit d'être assez foutu là
je vais m'en en l'air on a
d'autres solutions que d'appeler la
prison pour qu'ils aillent très vite
voir ce qui se passe mais après je pense
que quand vous savez Gradignan dans la
coursive il y a un surveillant pour
toute la coursive quand il y en a puis
voyez tous les petits drapeaux vous
savez les drapeaux c'est ces bouts de
papier que les maintenant vous
connaissez tous puisque vous étiez les
prisons qui qui passent à travers la
porte et il s'agite et qui font
de qu'ils entendent pas dans le couloir
et donc tout s'agit de tous ces petits
drapeaux s'agitent pour dire sur parce
qu'il y a pas de boutons d'appel
surveillant surveillant vient nous voir
mais quand on l'a agité un nombre de
fois énorme que personne n'est venu
parce qu'il y a personne je pense que on
a demandé des soins on a demandé le
dentiste on a dit
j'arrive pas à aller aux toilettes on a
dit je voudrais changer de cellule je
parce que moi je suis non-fumeur mais
que d'études sont fumeurs je voudrais
changer de cellule parce que mon code
est tenu me martyrise mais on se sent
totalement abandonné de l'État alors je
ne dis pas que en détention il y a pas
il y a des gens beaucoup plus fragiles
que dehors
s'arrête ça recolle quand même des gens
plus fragiles certainement mais il y a
quand même une forme d'abandon des
pouvoirs publics quand on est là dedans
j'imagine qu'il vous pousse pas à
l'optimisme et à se dire ça ira mieux
demain
et je pense que c'est tu veux ajouter
quelque chose André oui
la question du nombre des suicides
posent aussi celle de la présence des
malades mentaux en prison
qui sont on dit mais là aussi sans
statistiques véritable que 70% des
détenus prennent un traitement de la
sphère psychiatrique alors dans les
traitements de la sphère psychiatrique
elle est traitement de substitution il y
a les antidépresseurs il y a des petites
choses il y a aussi des antipsychotiques
là aussi on dit mais sans le prouver que
les problèmes de psychose touchent entre
un quart et un tiers de la population
pénale c'est peut-être beaucoup mais en
tout cas un car c'est assez simple assez
réaliste
et donc il y a un nombre très important
de de malade mentaux qui sont dans les
prisons les uns
parce que faisons l'objet de procédure
correctionnelle ils n'ont pas été
dépisté au stade de la procédure parce
que l'expertise psychiatrique n'est pas
obligatoire en matière correctionnelle
les autres parce que ils ont été
déclarés partiellement irresponsable
mais partiellement responsable et donc
ils ont été condamnés à de la prison
d'autres enfin parce que la prison
la une mauvaise influence sur leur santé
mentale mais en tout cas ce sont des
situations devant lesquelles
l'administration pénitentiaire est
démunie sont des détenus qu'elle ne peut
pas traiter qu'elle ne peut pas faire
sortir parce que les suspensions de
peine pour raison médicale en pleine
terre de psychiatrie sont rares ici et
de toute façon un peu impossible
concrètement parce qu'il n'y a pas de
lieu de sortie donc la question des
suicides me semble-t-il et aussi
directement corrélée à ça
bien merci chers collègues je suis donc
la fin de cette audition et je vous
remercie d'être rendu disponible pour la
commission des lois
voilà pour cette audition que vous
pouvez retrouver sur LCP.fr mais aussi
sur la chaîne Youtube de LCP à bientôt
pour un autre moment parlementaire